this just in Jack Bauer has had a sex
change in age reduction and is actually
in a movie life could be stranger all
right now going into Hannah I was really
skeptical I was expecting a bore fest I
was expecting like the American part to
I don't know why just was come to find
out Hannah has a nice bit of badassery
to it right so the story goes hannah has
lived in like godforsaken nowhere of
Snowville in a log cabin with eric bana
and he's just been training her to be a
badass all of her life her entire life
she goes outside in the snow she hunts
she works out she spars with Eric Bana
she learns to kill and rinse and repeat
and she's played by the little girl who
played Susie salmon from The Lovely
Bones
Ellis watch Stanley Tucci try to do
anything with that girl she will break
something off she is quite a badass
which makes her pretty much the most
productive sixteen-year-old I've ever
heard of most of them hang out in
arcades I'm just saying don't mean to a
lea name is 16 year old subscribers you
guys are all right but then she wants to
see more of the world so Eric van I was
like alright push this red button you
can see more of the world but the world
is gonna come after you namely the
redheaded played by Cate Blanchett
it turns out Eric Bana was like a secret
agent back in the day so yeah flipping
the button she does and they come and
well now we have our spy movie this girl
is doing all the hardcore awesome spy
like hiding up on the ceiling like
River Tam dropping down slicing throats
it's like Solid Snake got a sex change
and it's played by a 16 year old girl in
a movie now we'll pull all the cool
stuff that you see in the first third of
the movie after that the movie kind of
slows down for a bit she starts hanging
out with this family a really weird
family too and I see why the family was
really weird and exaggerated because a
lot of times in movies like this when
someone's like this you know emotionless
soldier when they see normal people
they're like oh you're weird but you
don't really see or feel how they think
they're weird but in this movie by
exaggerating the family you really see
you're like you're odd people and that's
exactly how she's oh I get it I feel it
awesome so it really worked but it kind
of slows down at that point you're like
come on kill but it's character
building stuff you know how that stuff
works and at the end of this movie I
felt like the movie just ends kind of an
anti-climatic kind of way I like a big
climax I like a big showdown you don't
really get that in this movie just kind
of happens and ends what the movie is
really good Eric Bana was pretty cool
too but you don't really see much of him
he does some stuff in the movie but all
in all it's all about the little girl
Eric Bana is a side character but I will
say that when the goes down it goes
down well the director in this
he's just a really good director so
props to that guy so the girl is a
badass Eric Bana school and Cate
Blanchett is a really big
effective filmmaking if I've ever heard
it so I will say give me this movie on
blu-ray check it out go see it it's
pretty good this girl can throw down
with the best of them but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]